immersion pour que ce plongeurs sapeurs
pompiers puissent descendre dans le
puits il aura fallu l'intervention de
deux services spécialisés d'abord les
pompiers du grimp le groupe de
reconnaissance et d'intervention en
milieu périlleux des hommes rompus aux
techniques j'escalade est aussi le
groupe des plongeurs l'exercice commun
du jour permet d'abord d'anticiper les
dangers d'une telle intervention
c'est déjà d'avoir un problème d'air ne
plus pouvoir respirer
c'est de ce pouvoir de se recevoir des
choses qui tombent aussi
c2c d'être gêné dans sa progression
parce que vous vouliez qu'il ya des
éléments déclencheurs de choses donc
c'est d'être gêné et puis c'est de ne
rien voir tout ça s'opère alors sur la
première plongée là il un peu de
visibilité sur ceux qui vont suivre avec
les particules en suspension
tout se fait quasiment à tâtons voilà
donc en fait il ya de nombreuses choses
qui rentrent de la plongée très
difficile et c'est justement parce qu'
une intervention dans un puits est peu
probable que la répétition des gestes à
l'entraînement est primordial n'arrive
pas souvent et justement c'est parce
qu'on n'est pas sur des interventions
courantes et habituelles voilà donc là
on est pas on est sûr de la gestuelle
qu'il faut vraiment faire régulièrement
l'entraînement pour le cas exceptionnels
où nous sommes amenés à le faire ce type
d'intervention
ça peut être sûr de la reconnaissance
dans un puits parce qu'on recherche
quelqu'un voilà où alors on a
l'assurance que quelqu'un est tombé dans
le puits ou un animal ou un être humain
voilà donc il faut aller chercher donc
ça rentre pleinement dans nos missions
et dans ce cadre là il faut pouvoir
comment il faut pouvoir le faire de la
meilleure façon possible le plus
rapidement possible dans toute sécurité
excellente condition physique sang froid
et haute technicité n'ont qu'un seul
objectif porter secours
c'est astreignant mais on n'a pas le
droit à l'erreur
on doit effectivement travailler
toujours en sécurité on a quand même peu
l'occasion de mettre en oeuvre nos nos
techniques et nos procédures sur de
vrais intervention ce qui est une bonne
chose malgré tout maintenant du coup bah
ça nous impose un entraînement régulier
et la mise en oeuvre régulièrement au
cours de manoeuvres d'entraînement de
nos pratiques
c'est important puisque bas tout en
gagner c'est du temps où la victime sera
sortie soit dégagée d'un d'un immeuble
sis et un immeuble pour le grimp dégager
d'un puits comme là avec nos collègues
plongeurs
donc j'ai du temps guen des heures et
des heures d'entraînement intensif qui
sont le prix à payer pour nous sauver
dans toutes les situations